hello and congratulations
so in preparation for this interview i
kind of went down the rabbit hole of
reading about your focus
on education and also the mfa program
you're a part of made me think of a
question
that i often ask and it's what was a
seemingly silly
question that you were afraid to ask on
one of your very first film sets that
you think
aspiring actors should know more about
yes it's an
easy answer perry easy i never had to
worry about hitting a mark
if on stage you just get in the general
vicinity of the light
but on film you've got to hit your mark
and i was always afraid to look down and
i wondered what the trick was is how to
find your mark
and a very gracious director the very
first tv thing i did he said
just look at the mark right before you
say your line that part we can cut out
and then go for it
look at something on the side it's a
landmark like a chair
or a table and use it as landmark and i
felt so much better he made me feel
at ease and i i still remember that even
now i
when i don't hit my mark sometimes i
think just look at it right before you
start
i like that that's a good one to back
pocket i got another question that i
love asking because i'm
always fascinated to hear about a
director's tell
behind the monitor when they really like
what you're doing or
in this case i guess it would be a zoom
call so what can you see
robert zemeckis do when you know he is
really liking a take you're giving
well first of all you need to know that
i did this movie
during the pandemic in my closet
in new york he's in california they sent
a microphone
a computer and an ipad so that the
animators could watch me because as you
can see
they're gonna i'm an animated person and
they're going to
hopefully be inspired by that for the
character zemeckis can see me i can see
him we can communicate and there was one
thing that we were doing and i
just ad-libbed something and he
started going kinda and i thought oh
he's shaking
is he okay and he goes no no i'm
laughing so
when he shakes i know he's good i admire
him quite a bit so i enjoy that
how do i that man when i first got the
script i thought oh they want me for the
evil witch i'm sure you know and then
he's like no no the mouse i was like
what but the far the part is is i got to
create that part and i got to be
directed by him
and now there's a special relationship
by someone that i admire and that i can
learn from and that i hope to work with
again
on set on an actual set so i can learn
from him some more
that would be incredible i hope that
happens
i want to put up a brief spoiler warning
for our audience because i did want to
ask you about the ending because i am
very curious to know what you thought
about the ending when you first read the
script and you saw that they changed the
story back to the book
as far as the kids staying mice i had
mixed feelings
and by the way there were there were a
couple endings i got
throughout the yeah so it kind of
switched back and forth but you know
i think the message this is getting back
to i want to speak really to my younger
fans i think the message here is and i
think is what we're saying with the film
don't be um by the way you look
don't worry about it lead with your
brain lead with your heart
and the things that make you unique and
different embrace them because that'll
probably be what makes you special
i like that message for people of all
ages
to wrap up here i have to ask you about
wicked because i love the book love the
show and i've been so so eager to see
that movie
but there was a recent setback with the
movie so
i think this will be very meaningful to
fans coming from you in particular
what do you think it is about the value
of retelling that story in the feature
film format that no matter the amount of
snags we encounter in the next couple of
months or years will guarantee
that that story will be seen on the big
screen at some point
perry i think it's an important story
for first of all as a
kid growing up in oklahoma i couldn't
get to broadway
i could we couldn't afford that so i
relied on television and books
and occasionally a tour that might come
through tulsa you know
um so what why not
why not make it a movie and let this
metoo movement
which we were doing before the me too
movement
this story between it wicked has the
themes i
like in a show it has the themes of
friendship
forgiveness and love
and between two women
you know the love story is really
between them too
and that's what i want up on that camera
i want it up on the screens
i want it on television so that people
who can't afford to go see the show can
watch it
i haven't thought about that i like that
spin on it though and i'm
very much here for it probably one way
or the other because i'm obsessed with
the story
thank you so much for your time today
huge congrats on the movie
thank you honey bye